He
is the only person whose baby picture was
flown into space, and whose body has been
preserved for decades after his death.
He pushed his version of Communism so far,
and for so long, that he was able to overthrow
the government of the largest country in the
world.
To some, he is a hero, and to others, he is
one of the most evil villains in history.
On Today’s Biographics, we are talking about
Vladimir Lenin- The man behind the Bolshevik
Revolution, and the founder of the Soviet
Union.
Early Life
The year was 1870, and Vladimir Ilyich Ulyanov
was born in a Russian provincial town called
Simbirsk.
He would eventually grow up to be most known
by his alias, “Vladimir Lenin” later in
life, and we will explain the origin of the
name later.
Most revolutionaries have a tragic backstory
of a young life of hardship, rising from the
lower classes to demand better treatment for
the downtrodden.
And many people are taught that this is the
case with Lenin, as well.
They try to say that his parents were descended
from serfs, and that he had to study hard
to break into the middle class.
Buxt the truth was that Lenin’s parents
were actually financially comfortable, and
by all accounts, he had a happy childhood.
His mother, Maria, was descended from a wealthy
Jewish family who was Swiss-German, so she
taught him French and German at home.
His father, Ilya, was the Director of Public
Schools for the entire province.
They were considered to be “hereditary nobility”,
and they were far more educated than the average
Russian.
This placed his parents in a group called
the “Intelligentsia”, who would debate
over philosophy and politics in their spare
time.
Many of the members of the Intelligentsia
became politicians who helped shape the new
laws of the nation, while others devoted their
life to pushing for a Russian revolution.
Vladimir and his older brother Alexander were
no exception.
His brother loved studying science in High
School, but there were no opportunities to
become a scientist in his small Russian village
like Simbirsk.
So Alexander moved to St. Petersburg to attend
university.
During this time, he joined a political study
group, and they began to discuss the failures
of the Romanov empire, and they believed that
the only way to save Russia would be to remove
them from power.
When he was 21 years old, Alexander joined
a terrorist group who attempted to assassinate
Tsar Nicholas II with a homemade bomb.
The terrorists were caught, and Alexander
and his friends were hanged for their crime.
Vladimir Lenin was 17 at the time that his
brother died, and just about to graduate High
School.
Even though he had gone through such a shocking
tragedy, he still managed to become the valedictorian
of his graduating class.
He went to law school with the intention of
becoming a lawyer.
But just a few months into his first semester,
he joined a demonstration of students who
were protesting against the school rules.
Since the Russian police were already watching
Lenin closely to see if he was also a terrorist
like his brother, the school saw his participation
in the demonstrations as a sign that he might
cause a lot of trouble.
So, he was expelled, and decided to educate
himself, instead.
The Sparks That Ignited a Revolution
The Tsar, Nicholas II, released the peasant
class from their serf status, meaning that
they no longer had to be indentured servants
to wealthy landowners.
While this helped relieve the difficulties
of a lot of people, it wasn’t a perfect
solution to the problems that the peasant
class was facing.
People were still in debt, and many struggled
to make ends meet.
The vast majority of people were illiterate,
and Russia was decades behind in progress
compared to the western world.
Members of the Intelligentsia were very unhappy
with the way things were going, and wanted
their country to move forward with progress,
just like the rest of the human race.
Lenin studied at law school, but he realized
that with his bad nerves, and his family’s
bad reputation from his brother being a terrorist
would make it impossible for him to get a
job as a lawyer.
Vladimir Lenin began his self-education by
reading Karl Marx and other revolutionary
writers.
He joined a Marxist study group, where intellectuals
met and discussed philosophy, and the possibility
of a Russian Revolution.
It was around this time that a major famine
spread through the land near his home.
Records of the 1891 famine vary drastically,
with some stating there were 300,000 deaths,
while others say it was closer to 5 million
people dying of starvation.
Lenin was fine, of course, since his family
was well-off, and he had plenty of money to
buy food.
He did nothing to offer aid to the people
dying around him.
He was actually happy about this, saying that
the worse things got in Russia, the better
it will become.
He knew that people needed to start dying
in the thousands before people angry enough
to want a revolution.
Karl Marx wrote that he believed that an industrialized
society would be most likely to create a revolution,
because he believed they will want to rise
against commercialism.
Vladimir Lenin rewrote a lot of what Marx
was actually saying.
Lenin wrote the idea that the revolutionary
Intelligentsia will guide the uneducated peasants.
Even though the philosophy was labeled as
“Marxism” all throughout the reign of
the Soviet Union, it is now called “Leninism”,
because it really was his own personal ideas,
not those of Karl Marx.
Lenin joined a socialist group that gained
access to a factory, where they started handing
out fliers to factory workers.
They were trying to make people angry about
their work situations, and want to demand
shorter hours and higher pay.
They were caught, though, because they accidently
let a police informant join the group, and
they were all arrested.
At the time, any form of revolutionary activity
was taken very seriously, and they all had
to serve time in jail.
He was 26 years old at the time he went to
prison, but it was nothing like what we imagine
a Russian prison to be.
Since he descended from a noble bloodline,
he was given a very comfortable place to live,
where he could wear whatever clothes he wanted,
read books, and received daily visits from
family and friends.
He was even allowed to continue writing his
revolutionary pamphlets and essays while he
was behind bars.
After 14 months in jail, he was exiled to
Siberia for three years.
In a way, this was actually great for him,
because he was given a government pension
for his living expenses.
He spent all of his time reading and writing
about the revolution, which is what he wanted
to do, anyway.
So, for him, this time in Siberia was more
like a very long writer’s retreat, and he
was actually very productive during his time
away.
His girlfriend was also arrested, and sent
to Siberia, too.
They got married, so that they could live
there in exile together.
While Vladimir Lenin was writing his revolutionary
ideas in Siberia, he would send them back
to his socialist friends, who would publish
his essays in their secret newspaper.
He made up a variety of pen names, so that
it seemed like multiple intellectuals were
all pushing for the same revolution, but it
was really just him.
The pen name he eventually stuck with was
“Vladimir Lenin”, which is what he is
remembered as today.
After being released from his time of exile,
he was 30 years old.
He and his wife moved to Munich, Germany,
where they could print their revolutionary
newspapers in Russian without getting in trouble
with the German police.
He would then have the papers smuggled into
Russia, with the help of fellow revolutionaries
who carried them in their luggage.
One of these co-conspirators was a young man
named Joseph Stalin, who was equally passionate
about the coming revolution, and would eventually
take Lenin’s place.
The Bolshevik Revolution
In most tellings of the Russian Revolution,
Vladimir Lenin’s rise to power always seems
very straight-forward.
He is always depicted as a well-respected
intellectual who was able to rise to power
almost immediately.
But that’s very far from the truth.
His revolution was a very long process, but
he never gave up trying to slither his way
into a place of power.
Vladimir Lenin had a real talent for stirring
up trouble.
Even amongst the Intelligentsia, he would
call anyone who disagreed with him his “enemies”,
and the sniveling “bourgeoise”.
Even though they were all middle-class socialists,
he had absolutely no patience for anyone who
did not agree with him 100%.
During one of their meetings, to discuss their
strategies about the revolution, he insulted
some of the socialists so strongly, they got
up and left.
While they were gone, he declared that his
ideals were the “Bolsheviks”, or the “Majority”,
while everyone else was the “Menshevik”
or “minority” party.
The name “Bolshevik” stuck from then on.
In 1904, Lenin got a bit stressed out from
all of this debating and discussing his philosophy
and handing out pamphlets which made him ill,
so took any entire year-long hiking holiday
in the Swiss alps with his wife, but the Bolsheviks
continued to do their own revolutionary work
while he was gone.
In 1905, there was a peaceful protest in St.
Petersburg in front of the winter palace.
People held up signs pleading for better working
conditions.
All they wanted was an 8-hour work day.
They even sang “God Save the Tsar” to
show their love and support for the royal
family.
But instead of listening to their request,
Tsar Nicholas II ordered his guards to shoot
at the crowd.
Thousands of people died, and it became known
as “Bloody Sunday”.
People were outraged, and began protesting
for workers rights all across Russia.
When Lenin heard the news, he abruptly ended
his vacation in Switzerland and decided to
come back to Russia.
He finally had the opportunity he had been
waiting for.
He began to preach to people that they needed
to organize and take action against the Tsar.
He got a little too excited about the idea
of a bloody revolution, and wrote how they
should pour hot acid on the royal guard, and
got into specific details about how to murder
someone... which was something that no other
revolutionary writer had done before.
However, there were still not enough revolutionaries
willing to fight and kill people on Lenin’s
behalf.
Many of the Bolshevik revolutionaries were
exiled to Siberia, and Lenin fled to Switzerland
before he could be arrested, too.
World War I put a pause on everyone’s revolutionary
plans.
Tsar Nicholas II left St. Petersburg behind
to join his men on the front lines.
Nicholas left his wife, Alexandra, in the
care of their spiritual advisor, Grigori Rasputin.
This man believed that he was the second coming
of Christ, and he believed that he had magic
healing powers given to him by God.
Many of the decisions Rasputin made were harshly
criticized, like putting his unqualified friends
in powerful positions.
Lenin still continued to write about his revolutionary
ideas from Switzerland, and encouraged soldiers
to turn their guns against their officers
during the war.
But almost no one was actually reading the
underground newspapers, except for the handful
of active Bolsheviks.
The vast majority of the Russian people were
eager to defend their country, but the war
was truly a disaster.
Millions of people died, inflation ruined
Russia’s economy, and women were standing
in long bread lines.
Tsar Nicholas II renamed St. Petersburg to
“Petrograd”, as a symbol of his devotion
to the Russian people.
For years, people had criticized the name
“St. Petersburg” because it sounded too
German, and “Petrograd” was much more
Russian.
Tsar Nicholas believed that this would somehow
prove his loyalty, but that gesture wasn’t
enough.
For the first time, thousands of Russian people
were trained in the military and knew how
to use guns.
Soldiers and police officers were just as
angry as the rest, and people were swarming
the palace to take over the Tsar all on their
own….And Lenin had nothing to do with it.
He wasn’t even there.
He was still in Switzerland, and he was panicking,
because the revolution was starting without
him.
The political parties were split into two
groups- the provisional government, which
was made up of the representatives called
the Duma, and the Worker’s Soviets, who
were controlled by the trade unions and made
up of the peasants, soldiers, and factory
workers.
Lenin knew that he was no match for the provisional
government’s leader, Alexander Kerensky.
He was a seasoned lawyer, and a master of
public speaking.
Kerensky resonated with the Duma, and since
Lenin was not actually a lawyer, he knew he
would lose in a political debate against him.
So he focused his efforts on trying to manipulate
the lesser educated Worker’s Soviets, instead.
When he arrived at the train station, Lenin’s
friends were there to greet him, and he hardly
said “hello” before standing up on a pedestal
to shout at the crowd that they had done an
awful job with the revolution, and that it
wasn’t going to be over until they took
down the provisional government.
Almost no one actually agreed with him, and
went about their business.
Even his fellow Bolsheviks no longer wanted
to print his essays, because it was such an
unpopular opinion.
The provisional government was leading Russia
back to war against Germany, and World War
I was still going on.
But soldiers were not happy to serve.
It was the reason why they had overthrown
the Tsar in the first place.
People wanted the war to be over.
Many of them abandoned their posts on the
battlefield, or completely refused to go in
the first place.
Lenin tried to stand up again and lead the
crowds of peasants, but someone from the provisional
government shouted that he was a German spy.
This made the crowd turn against him, and
he had to run away.
Alexander Kerensky could see that he was going
to cause a lot of trouble for the authority
of the provisional government, so he outlawed
the existence of the Bolshevik party.
Lenin needed to escape.
He put on a bad wig, shaved his beard, and
got on the next train to Finland.
Vladimir Lenin spent a very long time hiding
on a Finnish farm, continuing to write his
ideas and send them back to Russia.
Since no one was actually listening to him
or agreeing with his ideas, he decided to
take it by force.
One night in October of 1917, he snuck back
into Russia, and met up with his commerads
in Petrograd.
By this time, he had convinced more members
of the Worker’s Party to join his side.
He convinced his Bolshevik followers of the
Red Guard to break into the Winter Palace
for a coup-d’etat.
They captured the members of the provisional
government at gunpoint.
The Duma were arrested, taken to jail, and
Vladimir Lenin became the new leader of Russia
without ever being voted in.
Lenin’s Violent Reign
Vladimir Lenin addressed the crowd of Russian
peasants the morning after storming the winter
palace, and introduced himself as their new
dictator, and the leader of The Soviet Union.
Lenin promised them exactly what they wanted,
in the simplest words possible; “peace,
bread, and land.”
One of his first acts as leader was to end
the war with Germany.
People were happy, because that’s exactly
what they wanted all along.
Right from the beginning, he isolated himself
at the Kremlin in Moscow, so that he could
continue writing.
The Bolshevik party wasted no time spreading
propaganda that Vladimir Lenin was like a
kind old grandfather who only wanted the best
for the Russian people, and that they didn’t
have to worry anymore, because he was there
to take care of them.
In reality, he was bloodthirsty, and wanted
his revolution to be as violent as possible.
He told tenants to kill their landlords, and
encouraged violence against the upper classes.
He gave out the order to his Red Guard to
remove the Romanov royal family from their
palace.
At that time, the number of men who joined
in Lenin’s Red Guard had grown to 200,000,
and he had a small army to stand behind him.
Many of the Russian people protested, because
they loved the Romanovs, especially the young
children.
At first, Lenin lied, saying that they would
be kept somewhere safe.
But once he realized that they were too much
of a threat to his power, he ordered their
execution.
Since the family was being held in Siberia,
it took a very long time for the public to
learn about their deaths.
At first, people believed it was just Tsar
Nicholas who was killed, and that the women
and children were spared, it would take years
for the public to learn the truth of his brutality.
Lenin began implementing his communist government.
He proclaimed that every Russian citizen should
have good rations, but in order to do that,
the farms needed to be controlled by the government.
Farmers were not allowed to keep or sell the
food they grew, and all of the crops were
spread out among the entire nation.
People could no longer choose their jobs,
and were given employment in newly constructed
factories based on the needs of the country.
Some people were very happy about this, and
it gave them a sense of security.
Statues and paintings of him were erected
around Petrograd, and many called him a hero.
Not everyone was drinking Lenin’s kool-aid,
of course.
Plenty of people were furious with him for
ordering the death of innocent Romanov children.
In 1918, a woman named Fanya Kaplan attempted
to assassinate Vladimir Lenin.
She shot him twice at close range.
He was seriously injured, but he still managed
to survive.
Kaplan was arrested, and she refused to give
up the name of any of her co-conspirators.
She was executed in September of that same
year.
Lenin would recover from his injuries in the
hospital, but from that day forward, he showed
no mercy to anyone who expressed even the
smallest opinion opposing his rule.
Even though he always encouraged the peasant
class to stand up for their rights and rebel
against their government, it was no longer
okay to do so once it was his government.
Any time peasants or farmers tried to protest
against his new rules, they were killed without
mercy.
Those who opposed Lenin didn’t go down without
a fight, though.
In 1918, a group called The White Army battled
against the Red Army in a civil war, fighting
to take down the Soviet Union.
However, the White Army was not organized
very well, and they lost the war.
In 1920, farmers were angry that their grain
was being stolen from them for the “greater
good” of the Communist nation.
This began what is known as the Tambov Rebellion,
but they were all gassed by the Red Army,
and their crops were taken away from their
dead hands.
At least 50,000 people were interned, mostly
women, children, and the elderly - some of
them sent to the camps as hostages.
There were several other incidents like this,
and any rebellion among the Russian people
was quickly squashed.
Even after trying to make his political philosophy
work through threats of death and destruction,
Lenin knew when to call it quits.
When millions of people were on the brink
of dying from drought and famine, he decided
to temporarily stop communism, and allowed
farmers to keep the food they planted, and
sell the excess food for profit….Y’know,
a little thing called Capitalism.
This was a huge success.
People were no longer starving, and the economy
improved.
Once things had stabilized again, Lenin went
back to forcing food rations.
Unfortunately, not every leader who followed
in Lenin’s footsteps knew to take a break
from communism during times of famine.
And Lenin’s successor, Joseph Stalin, would
be remembered as one of the worst dictators
who ever lived.
Death and Legacy
When he was 54, Vladimir Lenin’s health
began to decline, and he had multiple strokes.
But even when he was in poor health, he was
trying to write in a journal to give commands
from his bed.
When he died in 1924, people were shocked,
and they were not expecting him to die so
young.
Hundreds of thousands of people showed up
to his funeral, even though it was well below
freezing temperatures.
People were sobbing, upset that the one man
who truly cared about them was now gone.
He did manage to make some improvement in
the economy, and there was so much pro-Lenin
propaganda that had been circulated, that
people believed that he was truly their savior.
Five days after Lenin passed away, the city
of Petrograd was renamed “Leningrad” in
his honor.
His body was embalmed so that people could
continue to visit him and pay their respects.
Vladimir Lenin’s reputation only became
more powerful after his death than when he
was alive.
He was like a legend who managed to change
not just Russia, but several other countries
throughout the world.
Communist leaders looked to him for inspiration
to run their own dictatorships.
The USSR continued for decades after his death,
and despite all of its setbacks, the system
lead to more progress than Russia had seen
in hundreds of years.
Before Lenin, the country was very far behind
the rest of the western world in terms of
industrialization, education, and modernization.
If it were not for all of the reforms made
by the Soviet Union, they may have never gotten
so far with the Space Race against the United
States, and they still may be lagging behind
today.
In 1991, the Soviet Union collapsed, and all
of the statues of Lenin were torn down.
Instead of seeing him as a hero, he is now
remembered as a villain.
Leningrad became St. Petersburg once again.
There is no telling how far the nation would
have progressed if it were not for the creation
Soviet Union, but one thing is for sure- Without
Vladimir Lenin, the world would be a very
different place today.